[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want what's up we
got tesh here hey and we got michael
here hi how you been buddy good good
chilling
i went to disneyland recently yeah
that's pretty interesting and the
amazing thing about my disneyland
experience was that there were
absolutely no lines whoa it's like uh
you know how like certain rides like
radiator springs right um it's usually
like a three hour wait what but no lime
yeah no lance like for me was it raining
no it wasn't raining at all it was like
there was absolutely no one there it was
uh i think because like school just
started or something you go on monday i
went on a wednesday which was basically
the same exact day did you go along no i
want my girlfriend
for sure one like because that's cool
but it was good
so so does she have a preference is she
like i want to go to this land or any of
that kind of [ __ ] she does like um i
feel like we like to begin or she likes
to begin the land in um what is it
california adventures and then from
there like you know after 1pm we like to
migrate over to disneyland you could do
both in one day you have a strategy this
is like that's smart you get the
partners real disney goers have
strategies
i didn't think that there was enough
hours in a day to do both there isn't
unless there are absolutely no lines
and so like for uh really popular rides
that usually take three hours um we
basically went through the turn stall
walked to the very front got in the cart
and then we went on the ride sometimes
can you do twice yeah i mean we could
have done it like five times in a row
probably it was that empty i mean it
wasn't that empty but it was sounds
pretty empty very empty imagine paying
for vip that day and you're like oh
that would have been me i would all the
people all these [ __ ] people getting
to get in
i've been pissed nowadays they don't
even offer that they don't have fast
pass they don't have any of that [ __ ] so
you have to like make a reservation on
the day so you have to buy tickets did
you do that make a reservation we so
like you have to make a reservation for
um to go to the park right so we did
that ahead of time and then like for two
of the riots i think it's like the new
star wars ride and uh this new like
spider-man ride you have to make a
reservation for that as well and so yeah
bless you bless you i don't have
homework
that's allergies though
just trouble
his natural passages is clear you have
to go jack off now apparently according
to the previous article what was what's
your take on are you a star wars fan uh
yeah and i am i guess what's your take
on the land the land i thought it was
very cool like um
it's
i guess like what i don't like about it
compared to other theme parks is that
there's not that much stuff to do i feel
like there's like two rides there's
it's more it's more of just walking
through the world that's true that's
wack i've never i haven't been there yet
but the world is sick though like if you
feel like you're in the star wars yeah
but it's
but they they haven't even put that in
the movie that planet is not in a
[ __ ] star wars movie
no i thought they had like the bar and
that stuff no they're making oh yeah it
looks like that people go to to the bar
and they also go to buy very expensive
lightsabers yeah of course yes what's at
the bar dude that's a magical experience
they're pretty cool though they're
pretty [ __ ] can you play poker with
boba fett i don't know i didn't go to
the bar
boba fett doesn't exist right at this
point or whatever what's the timeline i
don't know dude
between the two shittiest of the star
wars movies the before rise of skywalker
and after the last jedi i want the band
that's the band yeah they did it they i
did not go to the barbie the [ __ ] man go
to the [ __ ] barber wants to hear this
[ __ ] star wars disneyland 4 man 1pm
it was one pizza and when we were there
and so i was like well i don't want to
go drinking at one pm i have other rides
yeah dude get a bottle of water you lose
pina colada with an umbrella virgin pina
colada with an umbrella surprisingly
like there was a line for that thing
but i was like well i got rides around i
don't have time to go to the bar i got
rides to ride baby
hey not today i got rides right he's
like [ __ ] you losers
did you see any of the disney disneyland
gangs that are there that wear the biker
jackets oh yeah the disneyland gang so i
learned all about this what's the
disneyland yeah what's in his landing
game yeah so like i learned about this
because the show was on it was a disney
owned show so they used to take us to
disneyland once in a while for press and
then you see people in biker yeah
there's gender
they're dead
they have patches like like boy scouts
almost whatever you mean like like a
biker gang with the patches in the back
like
what are they like the goofy the goofy
guys donald duck you see like this guy
who's like shredded who looks like you
crush your skull and then he's got like
minnie mouse like right here what is
that yeah if you haven't seen them
you ever see a mascot there's like a
group of mascots and there's way on
somebody
it's the guy
he's at the bottom of the pile
every fight is caused by one of those
i didn't see that but um just curious
because like if they're not there it
must be a really empty but what are they
though they're super fans
yeah yeah so i guess they get like they
dress up yeah like we could all wear
like jk news biker disneyland we get
beat up bro
there was one white guy who wasn't
racially motivated yeah how was that
rachel weren't any whites defend oh
another white
that's always popular
but everyone else was asian and they got
totally beat up
mike did you go on the new rides like
the the ones you had to make
reservations for i did so i went on the
uh the new star wars ride you need a
reservation for you make a reservation
the new one the rise the rise rise of
the resistance maybe have you done it
yet or no no i was there for the
beta period
and it felt like that
the ride didn't even work yeah it was
like three days well no no no no not
that ride wasn't even open yet i was
there for like when the land first
opened like that first couple days and
so like they only had the millennium
falcon ride which is like an ass party
yeah what's the deal with that is that
good just whatever dude
were you it's an ass
it's a video game you're just like
moving around like a little bit what's
the definition of an ass party by the
way just think of it
that's what sounds fun that's what i'm
saying it's i want to go to this i want
to go to ass party a lot of strippers
the ass party no no no yeah it was not
good not good but it's a big star wars
shopping mall basically and by then it
was too full to even get into the bar so
we couldn't really do anything you're
just walking around and then as i'm
walking out of the land and i'm a huge
star wars fan i love this [ __ ] as i'm
walking out people like trying to high
five me like how was it and i'm like it
sucked
it's a total ass party back there you
know how much ass is in there
they're waiting for like hours to get in
and you know
i didn't like it you have to make
reservations for individual rights for
these two at the moment so it's like
because they're really popular and they
just came out it's like reservations
open at 7 00 a.m and i think it's what
12 p.m or 1 p.m something like that how
how do you get it and so basically you
have to download their app you go on
their app and then it's like it's like
you're buying concert tickets or
sneakers or something it's like right
when it hits like seven a.m you have to
basically you know tap tap tap on your
phone and say boom i wanna ride on on
the day of on the day off in the morning
i gotta get that app yeah i gotta get
that out i was the right and we just
can't it was pretty cool like i feel
like the whole thing felt like a star's
activation like like in a kind of like
an immersive experience and so you
basically do do you know what it is or
what star wars i'm not aware no no no no
so um so basically there's parts where
it's like um
you get to see like different things and
then there's parts where um it feels
like you're walking through like one of
the
it's like the deaths the death stars
star destroyer star destroyer thank you
steve you know obviously i don't watch
this stuff so uh the death star is the
[ __ ] moon i saw i started it's the
one that looks like a big ass and then
it blows up and it's half an hour no i
saw pictures of like the huge star
destroyer room with like all the
stormtroopers and yeah it's like like
when i walked into that room i was like
pretty blown i was pretty blown away i
was like [ __ ] this feels like some next
level stuff right here what about the
other ride the other reservation ride
the other one was this um spider-man
ride where it's kind of like one of
those ones where you uh you're shooting
stuff and oh wait like the buzz
lightyear the toy toy story one yeah
like i'm kind of like that and i swear
that gun's broken dude
because i always get a shitty score
it's probably just you but the buzz
lightyear was whack bro oh it's fun but
it's not as good as the toy story one is
that which one you gotta pull yeah
that's the toy story that toy store one
yeah that's one of california adventure
the buzz lightyear is the one where you
shoot the [ __ ] yeah yeah but yeah you
could shoot right at the [ __ ] thing
and it won't even register yeah really
yeah sometimes i feel like for this one
like for the spider-man one you just
kind of have to like you know like
you're shooting are you doing this [ __ ]
yeah you do that yeah i mean i mean you
can also just basically punch the thing
as well and it'll it's not as fun dude
are you in there with your chicken like
this isn't how i shoot [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
always takes it in stride he's the best
but um i thought it was really
interesting that like when we went in
indiana jones um
there was this person next to me
recording the whole ride what like a
walk through like a walk through like oh
for youtube for i think it was for
youtube like she had her phone out and
then she was the light on too the light
was on so that was kind of annoying oh
you should have ruined it you you've
been like i'm on jk news [ __ ] you more
views for us or just start playing like
a copyright song yeah
so like and then i went home and i
noticed that she's not the only one
there are like tons of these things
where people just basically put the
whole ride's experience on the internet
oh i've watched them
he's angry about that no no because i
remember when i was a kid
one of my most visceral memories was
thinking i was going to die because i
was going to fall into lava
and it was during the back of the future
ride but like i was a little kid right
and i go to my dad and i'm like dad was
that real lava and he's like i'm so
[ __ ] lit
so like for years i wouldn't even go to
school and i'd be like i almost [ __ ]
died in lava and because like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
so then i watched this they had a ride
and i was able to watch it and i was
like oh yeah it's totally i'm just a
stupid [ __ ] kid yeah but you know
today's video is brought to you by
draftkings ah
it's been a great start to the nfl
season and it's only getting better at
draftkings the official daily fantasy
partner for the
nfl
station
with a certified badge draftkings is
putting new customers in the center of
the action with a free shot at millions
of dollars in total prizes oh my good
did you say seven figures that's a lot
of money man why best time to be a new
customer my goodness that's a lot of
money and prizes it's simple just pick
your lineup stay under the salary cap
and see how your team stacks up against
the competition feel the nfl action like
never before with a free shot at
millions of dollars in total prizes damn
i just can't get over the mill that's a
lot of money draftkings is safe it's
secure and it's also reliable do you
think anything the nfl does is gonna be
unreliable no they said this is
draftkings and we are going to say this
is our official place to play and the
best part is you can deposit and
withdraw your money whenever you want
man download the draftkings app now and
use the code off the wrecker that's
o-f-f-t-h-e-r-e
this week new customers that's you can
get a free shot at millions of dollars
in total prizes
enter the code off the record to get a
free shot at millions of dollars in
total prizes that's off the record only
at draftkings the official
daily fantasy partner of the nfl
wonderful there's a minimum 5 deposit
requirement eligibility restrictions
apply go to draftkings.com for the
details
do they still have the back of the
future right now
do you guys remember the draft do you
guys know the fact that the whole place
would catch up
what about uh earthquake when you're in
the subway ceiling collapse they don't
have that anymore we're the subway and
then it floods and [ __ ] no like and it's
right next to the back to this it's like
walking dead now or something this is
jaws backdraft king kong e.t yeah et bro
western town floods yes i think they
still have that they still have that
yeah i mean they added some stuff
pirates of the caribbean is disney so
right i hate how the pirates ride became
the pirates of the caribbean right well
it was always they don't even chase the
girls but they took like but they they
added a lot more johnny depp yeah yeah a
lot more drowning depth i don't like
that
and they took out the edge that you
mentioned it used to be it used to be a
treasure island
[Laughter]
it used to be real man it used to be
real
it needs to be real pirates
you should go on that ride in the pirate
card i think they see my mom they'd be
like we're gonna [ __ ] take whatever's
in their birth right
why are these chicks voting yeah
this is my pirates ride the good old
days man
yeah because they got in trouble for the
guy chasing
the girl and then they switched out
remember the fat one chase the the girl
that was gonna have a sign said winches
for sale yeah
dude that's i just remember that yeah it
says like women voting here yeah it's
like oh
yeah everyone's pissed about that
damn that was my favorite ride though
dude it was a sick ride bro i liked it
because you can get to chill and it's
like kind of colder you would take a nap
i wouldn't fall so they have the
restaurant now that's like oh yeah the
blue bayou the justin
yeah that movie is in disneyland
honestly when they when they came out
with the blue bayou like movie trailer i
was like are they making a [ __ ] movie
about the [ __ ] restaurant because
they did they made a movie about jungle
cruise right and i'm like who the [ __ ]
what who wants to watch that movie yeah
justin chan yeah you're not even a
pirate no not not blue by you i don't
need the [ __ ] jungle cruise movie who
wants to watch that did you watch it no
it made a ton of money did it yeah i
would imagine it would because i don't
think it broke even it didn't oh really
i need the internet for that but i'm the
way okay jungle quiz movie box office
emily blunt the rock you know one of my
favorite things at disneyland though was
the was a little robinson crusoe island
that you could just [ __ ] around and run
around at remember 300 million probably
i think they still have that no i think
they still have that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
it's like a little island you just run
around and there's bridges and [ __ ] oh
yeah they did have that the one you
gotta get to on a ferry yeah you gotta
take a little boat or or you can canoe
there yourself which i don't know if
that was always there but i have some
people canoeing yeah we went on a little
boat you can canoe at disneyland yeah
you can communicate it's a [ __ ] awful
experience they're just like we have a
solution to coven you do everything by
yourself
and we'll charge you double the amount
you're you're also with other people
though so it's like not like um it's not
like you have one side so you can be
lost with a bunch of [ __ ] basically
and there's also the uh i guess like the
person who takes you around and tells
you to went to canoe but i was thinking
the same thing because it was like i
don't want to pay money to have to work
i already feel like i'm doing that with
web shooters by the way
when did you go last week i went uh two
weeks ago september 1st
so if you want to go go yeah i was
thinking about doing it time to go i
never been to california adventure you
should definitely go it's really it's
pretty cool that's the best part the
guardians of the galaxy right is really
cool i mean you won't but yeah so it's
wasted on you you theoretically could if
you wanted to oh yeah you could drink in
the star wars land too i heard they have
good drinks but couldn't get in they
have you know galaxy inspired cocktails
they have good micheladas over there in
a california adventure man if i'm not
being held up by chewbacca i don't want
to go that's what i'm saying dude
look i don't like the new star wars
movies personally but so when i see like
any of the first orders here i'm like uh
whatever
yeah and do they still rob you in the
train
the what oh is that nothing
i'm sorry but whoever robbed you was a
genius
it was part of the show good for them
they're like just play along it's arena
you can just hand it to me we'll get it
we'll give it back to you at the blossom
fountain man i never got my water back
[Music]
that was a really good show wait did
they do that disneyland or probably
knott's berry farm huh you don't know
the difference between disney and knox i
was so young you have character do they
have characters no but i think they're
going to be soupy because you're in a
train you're in the train oh yeah
peanuts is that not a bandits come in
and then they they basically stick
people up then that's nuts they take
somebody away and i always wanted to be
taken away and i was
you like take me yeah cause i wanted to
be a part of the bandits group and i
thought that you could be a bandit the
whole day that actually sounds like fun
yeah well i think that's not it's either
nuts or santa's village i think
is there even a train at disneyland
is the one that goes around
yeah but they're not robbing people
they're not robbing nobody yeah that's
not on brands no no definitely not okay
well i guess it's not very funny i got
robbed just slowly realizing no what are
you talking about they won't even point
at disney bro they will do this [ __ ]
they don't even so you could stick a gun
in your face on stitchers we weren't
allowed to point guns at each other's
heads
because it's a disney show so like if a
gun was being pointed at somebody it had
to be like on the shoulder like their
leg or their arm or i don't even know if
we could go like to the back that's very
specific
only to maine
just like shoot somebody in the kneecap
very that's just terminator 2. so
interesting
crazy very terminator too i haven't been
in so long do they still have the small
world yeah yeah they still have that did
they okay the [ __ ] pc people didn't
ruin that [ __ ] thank god they're all
multicultural
it's still good oh it's been pc yeah but
they have all the different like
versions of the small world song in each
world to their culture oh but they're
going to be like that's cultural
appropriation oh no nothing is safe
they're all good it's all good yo but i
heard toontown is dunzo right there's no
more to town gutted what's two-day that
was my favorite man toontown is gone the
team town sucked ass though which one
was two what was two take that back see
exactly we can't remember what happened
there let me ask you this what did you
do in toontown other than take stupid
pictures of you in the jail bars like
this i got mickey's autograph dude you
can't make this out of everywhere first
[ __ ] celebrity i went to donald
duck's house got an autograph and i went
to mickey's house got an autograph who
had more cocaine
dude for sure bro
long time ago with you guys like nine
years ago
no i don't know we we went though i
forgot but i was with it was with you
guys and you had a little autographed
book no no we didn't go to toontown
during that time because everyone said
it was lame and in my heart i was like i
wanted to revisit my childhood and [ __ ]
but i couldn't
but i did finally ride the ghost ride
because i was too [ __ ] scared to ride
that as a kid the haunted mansion i
bailed dude i remember i waited in line
with my cousin and when we got to that
circle room i walked in and i said [ __ ]
that and i phoned down dude and he was
so pissed when you were a kid that was a
scary [ __ ] of yours
you know like the elevator that goes up
and it's all scary and then you look up
and there's a lady hanging no the worst
part was when you bail the chair and it
spins you and then it shows you the
mirror and then it shows you as a
skeleton and you're like this is it i'm
going to hell yeah and you would you you
could make out on those all the time oh
dude you get handies in there
yeah dude you write it like seven times
every one of those
seats has had someone getting their dick
handed handled it yeah for sure with the
ghost in the middle in the middle you're
like i don't want you taking home with
it
i was there for my high school trip or
whatever the [ __ ] they had to keep
stopping the haunted mansion like stop
[ __ ] touching each other and [ __ ]
yeah dude
wait wait but then if someone is someone
that security you know is watching
everyone touching they would halt the
ride yeah
that person who slapped hands you know
yeah yo what are you doing
and they make you [ __ ] separated [ __ ]
on grad night dude everybody was [ __ ]
around and grind tonight no no yeah yeah
grinder nights i was like damn grind i
was like high school had a grind night
that's cool that was that was big in our
high school
didn't they do that where they were like
um they had disneyland overnight and you
could just be there till like the
morning or whatever they would do that
they would do that like grad night you
guys ever been to grad night yeah i grew
up in new york overnight was like
it wasn't overnight though it was like
you get there at 6 00 pm and then you'd
leave at like 3 a.m and then you would
go was it just your school or a bunch of
other schools a bunch of other schools i
see a bunch of other schools and they
would do it so you guys never done that
it sounds like a disaster
it really does sound like i don't know
me kids got in trouble my high school
for like doing ecstasy or doing drugs
and [ __ ] and they get they got caught
like they thought like they were so
slick and [ __ ] you know they got caught
doing drugs in disneyland yeah they're
hot at least they missed a grad night
without getting expelled that's
incredible couldn't walk though that's
what the whole punch moves out oh you
can't walk
that was like the whole [ __ ] thing i
remember my dad asked me if he had to
come to my high school graduation
because he was just like he was unsure
if it was a big deal or not because it's
like
such a like a useless accomplishment
he's like do i have to come and i was
like i think so
and then he was impressed that i
graduated in the top ten
or ten people but he didn't even know
the whole time i'm like dad do you
really think i was that stupid
well they didn't check your report cards
and stuff my dad didn't my mom did like
if i ever got a bad grade and like i had
to get my parents signature i'd run up
to my dad right as he was taking a [ __ ]
like i'd be like dad i'm like i'm like
yo can you sign this and he'd be like
what is this i'm like ah just my math
test then it would be like an 82 like
whatever right and you'd be like why'd
you get an 82 and i was like i just
[ __ ] up and you'd be like okay don't
do it again and then like and then he's
like in the middle no joke obtained he's
on the back oh yeah yeah
i was like don't do it again yeah
exactly
you're smart dude because it was the
only way to avoid the conversation of
of like i just didn't study or like i
just [ __ ] up which were usually the
only two answers like he's always taking
a [ __ ] he goes [ __ ] the only break i get
from [ __ ] hand surgery he's taking a
[ __ ] and so my mom would get pissed
because she'd go in for the future
teacher parent conferences and like not
know my dad would have like a vague idea
of what was going on and then but like
my mom was the person who did all the
school stuff
that's why my mom's like you can't give
it to him i'd be like why he's my parent
too
okay mom where are you gonna take a [ __ ]
i'm like dad lets me go to the bathroom
when he takes a [ __ ] you don't let me
but i knew because he'd always he'd
smoke a cigarette have his cup of coffee
and then go take a [ __ ]
and then and then take a shower and go
to work so i knew because you could see
it coming i knew every day that's what
he did dude 10 30 on a thursday
this guy's taking the [ __ ]
and i was like it's like automatic bro
i've been doing this show for [ __ ]
yeah every single time he's in there
every time it's amazing so it would be
hilarious i'd catch him
catch him right at the same time every
day at the top the staircase with his
cup of coffee he had just smoked a
cigarette and i'll be like dad sign this
like as i'm going down the stairs
getting ready from school like and it
would just be like just passing ships in
the night
like that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you